as the years roll on it becomes
impossible to watch certain films and tv
shows through the lens their directors
intended
sometimes just because a cameo or a role
that seemed like a fun gag at the time
takes on a completely different tone o.j
simpson's appearances in the naked gun
franchise
spring to mind as does seth macfarlane's
work on star trek enterprise
during the years family guy was off the
air sometimes these appearances make you
go
huh while other times you might say hey
look who it is and nobody induces both
of those responses
more than donald trump his surprising
cameo appearance in home alone 2 lost in
new york
stands out today is basically the only
thing anyone clearly remembers about the
film
here's a brief recap kevin mcallister
who ends up in new york and on his own
for a second time
runs into the celebrity businessman in
the halls of the plaza hotel
excuse me where's the lobby down the
hall and to the left
thanks in a recent interview with
insider
home alone 2 director chris columbus
described the delicate process
of getting trump onto the silver screen
the secret it seems lane wanting to
borrow his stuff
columbus mentioned that to shoot in most
new york city locations
you pay a fee and you're allowed to film
there for home alone 2 the production
approached the plaza hotel
which trump owned at the time for
permission to shoot some scenes in the
lobby
columbus further elaborated trump said
ok
we paid the fee but he also said the
only way you can use the plaza is if i'm
in the movie
so we agreed to put him in the movie and
when we screened it for the first time
the oddest thing happened
people cheered when trump showed up on
screen so i said to my editor
leave him in the movie it's a moment for
the audience but he did bully his way
into the movie
in 2017 matt damon relayed a similar
account of trump's cameo clause to the
hollywood reporter
according to damon the deal was that if
you wanted to shoot in one of his
buildings you had to write him in a part
director martin bress had to write
something incentive a woman
and the whole crew was in on it you have
to waste an hour of your day
donald trump walks in and al pacino is
like hello mr trump
you have to call him by name and then he
exits you waste a little time so that
you can get the permit
and then you can cut the scene out but i
guess in home alone too they left it in
the plaza hotel has a storied history of
pop culture appearances
having served as a setting for f scott
fitzgerald's the great gatsby in 1925
and as the main backdrop to the eloise
children's books trump who has since
moved on to other korea avenues
purchased the plaza in march of 1988 for
390 million dollars
or around 860 million dollars when
adjusted for inflation
by the time home alone 2 was released in
november of 1992
the hotel had accumulated more than half
a billion dollars of debt
the new york times reports that trump's
lenders took the majority share of the
business
in quote exchange for giving more
favorable terms as part of a
pre-packaged bankruptcy agreement
while home alone 2 was probably trump's
most successful cameo
it was far from his only one in 1989 he
portrayed himself in the critically
maligned boderic romantic crime comedy
ghosts can't do it earning a coveted
golden raspberry award
for worst supporting actor fans of it's
always sunny in philadelphia will be
excited and also disappointed to learn
that he appeared in nightmare
i miss you night man so bad
unfortunately that's not the nightmare
we're talking about here we're
referencing a superhero television show
from the mid 90s in one episode an
escaped convict morphs into trump so he
can withdraw money from a bank
and of course we can't forget about this
one
oh my god
however no trump cameo has garnered
quite as much attention
as the seven seconds of screen time he
accumulated in home alone too
in 2019 his appearance in the film was
thrust back into the spotlight after the
canadian broadcasting company aired a
version of the film
that had cut trump seen for time leading
to a social media fury from their
neighbors to the south
meanwhile did you know that scarlett
johansson was in home alone 3
for some reason nobody ever talks about
that what
his face doesn't look that bad his body
is covered
would that include his buttock region
shut up check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite celebs are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]
you